and I looked at my friends who were
successful and they were all
concentrating on the thing they did best
and once I learned that
a lot of doors opened up for me
Don how many office jobs or day jobs
have you had in your lifetime in my
entire lifetime let me see what kind of
normal jobs that I have
when I was 17 I only when I was about
12 I had a paper route for a while and
this I delivered a new neighborhood
newspapers when I was 17 I worked a
month and a half
in a greeting card and a wrapping paper
company in Chicago
and then if I worked once in the during
Christmas vacation for a month and a
half for Father's Book Company in
Chicago putting
bins together and stocking shelves of
books and then when I moved to
California as an adult
um I had a I had a girlfriend whose
mother didn't believe that writing was a
real job so to impress the mother I took
a job at an advertising agency
in the daytime and then make a little
more money I worked in a bookstore at
night so the only time I was home was
when I was sleeping or in between the
two jobs
and um I think that was pretty much it I
don't think any of these jobs lasted
more than about a month and a half
has it been your life's mission to not
work a quote-unquote day job yeah I I
my my life's Mission really was not to
work in a regular job and I've been able
to sustain myself all these years doing
that because I'm so
uh passionate about that so Furious
about that then I'll I'll go to Great
Lengths to Network and and make
connections and take chances and risks
and things and um it worked out for me
you know or most people would just take
the easy way out and take the job at the
supermarket or waiting tables in a
restaurant or an office job or something
like that I couldn't do that I couldn't
work
uh uh you know eight hours a day five or
six days a week doing the same thing
year after year working for somebody I
probably didn't like or respect anyway
so
um yeah I've made a real point to uh
survive without having to get a regular
normal job what if someone told you that
they didn't think it was possible to
make money as an artist for the rest of
your life or maybe someone did tell you
that well I grew up in Chicago and we
were told that all the time
we were told that you know uh
you're going to be starving most of the
time and all these people with
connections I mean I didn't have any
connections in any of the businesses I
got in really
um I knew a few people like in the comic
book business and but that was about it
my movie connections were all done you
know the hard way I made amateur movies
when I was a kid and I kind of learned a
lot of things about filmmaking by doing
it and because in those days there
weren't any books that told you how to
do it you had to figure out how to edit
and do special effects and makeup and
all that kind of thing on your own you
have to make it up as you went along and
um I learned a lot that way but uh
I I was called by my high school once
they knew I was going to be in town my
high school in Chicago
if I would speak to the
creative writing classes the English
classes and I got up there and I was
talking and I was I pretty much made it
a q a
and uh the only things anybody was
interested in like what kind of car I
drove when did I go to parties and all
this sort of thing
and uh
well finally one guy raised his hand
and this is right when Ronald Reagan got
elected president and he said well we
know you know we're from Illinois here
we know that none of us are ever going
to get in the acting business or the
writing business or the art business or
become president I said well the
president you got right now is from
Illinois and they there was silence
after that but yeah my family
um most of the people in my family
didn't know
until the day they died what I did for a
living I was the black sheep because I
was the one without the job and we would
have like these Thanksgiving dinners and
Christmas dinners all the relatives
would come over and we'd sit around the
table and people would start telling
what oh what their kids had done and
what was new in their lives and they
would skip over me they wouldn't even
ask me what I was doing because they
knew
it wasn't it wasn't anything they could
relate to
and I was trying to make some points
once within with an uncle who was
visiting us uh we were sitting in the
living room while everybody else was in
the kitchen and I had a new book that
had just come out with my name on it
as author and um I showed he said what
have you been doing lately and I showed
him this book and he looked at it and he
looked at him and finally he said
ah I am I am finally proud of you
you finally have a job
you work in a print shop you are an
apprentice printer he couldn't
understand that the words in that book I
wrote and I just at that point said
I'm not going to buy that anymore we're
trying to impress people that just don't
get it or don't want to get it
how much of a creative career do you
attribute to luck
I attribute a lot of it to luck because
you know bad luck and good luck I I
believe luck is simply
taking advantage of or not taking
advantage of serendipitous situation
that comes your way
and give you
a couple examples one is I used to be
the musicians union and I used to play
in a lot of rock and roll bands and
things they were you know we played at
weddings and parties and things like
that but never the big time which is
what I always wanted to be I wanted to
be a rock star and a friend of mine
happened to be at the Musicians Union
reading the bulletin board
and he called me up when he got home and
said hey I saw this
notice on the bulletin board somebody
starting up a new band and they're
looking for a bass player and he was a
bass player he said I'm not going to
bother her with this things always turn
out to be phony why don't you try so
give me the number so I called up it
turned out to be a band that was
was a little bit down the road was
produced by Michael netsmith who was one
of the monkeys and we for two years we
were recording doing albums
you know playing important gigs and he
resented me the rest of my aggressive
and the rest of his life he's dead now
but because I stole that from him that's
what he believed I stole that job that
gig from him that opportunity another
time
I went down to the I was living in an
apartment building and I went down to
the mailbox to see if I had any mail and
as I opened my mailbox a woman walked by
the outside on the sidewalk she stopped
and she looked at me and I had pretty
long hair back then and she said
are you 17. I said no I'm like
21 or so I was I was pretty old already
he says well I'm an agent they're
casting a TV commercial in an hour come
go to this address tell them you're 19.
so I went down there
there's a whole line of young actors out
there with their stage mothers you know
they're reading scripts and they're
getting rehearsing you know I went in
there cold
didn't have any stage mother or agent
with me I just went in there cold
and I did the audition and uh I got the
I got the I got the gig and it turned
out to be for a a union
uh brick hairspray commercial with Dick
Clark oh wow and uh I lived over that
commercial for about two years I just
did it cold and they liked the way I did
it but those are examples of just half
happening to be someplace now I'd gone
down to check my mail 10 minutes before
or after I wouldn't have known about it
if my friend hadn't have gone to the
um Musicians Union Bulletin Board and
turned down the notice he saw on there I
wouldn't have known about that either
and that kind of thing happens to me all
the time but I'm a very social person I
get out I Network I meet people and a
lot of times those people think about me
and hire me for something and it's they
used to say it's not what you know it's
who knows that's not it either it's who
knows you that's the important thing
and it sounds like you're not afraid to
take a chance it sounds like you were
willing to go out on a limb in case it
didn't work out you know no I've take
chances all my life and I admire people
who are Risk Takers and I don't mean
necessarily jumping off a building or
something you know to prove there was
stunt in the end but but to make
business risks they put their money into
something that everybody else says is
going to fail but they know in their
heart of hearts it's a solid thing and
and even if it doesn't take off they
know they've done their due diligence
they've done their part they've done
their best to make it take off and
that's a great thing for for me making
movies isn't so much the money coming
back it's going through that experience
of making the movie seeing it all come
together uh step by step by step and
hoping that it will be successful but if
it wasn't successful wow you had a great
time during your life going through that
process says what do you tell someone
who wants to be a full-time Creator but
they they think that they need their day
job
well I say
to succeed at anything like this the the
Arts let's see acting music
writing whatever
you've got to give it your 100
and that means you have to make yourself
available during the day and it's
strange hours and things
and you have to learn how to tighten the
belt you have to learn how to starve for
a while you know in those lean years
because if you don't I had a friend who
was a very good actor he came out here
from Indiana
and he was a good looking guy and he had
you know he would look good on camera he
was a pretty he was a good actor but he
you know he'd been brainwashed by the
people back in Indiana
you gotta you got to have something to
fall back on so he took a job at a major
Studio I won't say which one but a major
Film Studio One one of the major studios
in the security department
and they got really good at security and
he got promoted and that's what he
became a security guard
because he couldn't send the money down
to steady work
what's more important to a creative
career Talent or an understanding of
business
uh John Millie is used to tell me that
surviving
as a creative person is the director or
writer or something
it's uh
sixty percent what I think I think is
that 40 percent
Talent
and sixty percent used car salesmen I
think it's more like about 50 50. that's
one mistake a lot of creative people
people make they have no business sense
they don't know how to manage their
money they don't see a scam when it
comes I mean I learned all these things
the hard way and and sometimes teaming
up with a business person and that was
very uh important when I started my
first film company
um there were three of us
I was only moving I had no business
sense at all me I was just let's make
the movie let's go out there and do it
one partner was strictly business he had
no knowledge of or really interested in
the movie business he just want to make
money and the third was sort of a
combination between the two of us and we
got along great and he did all our
contracts and then if they make sure we
weren't getting cheated and it was left
to the other two uh to make the films
and to turn them out but I know so many
creative people that are really really
good and they don't know how to you know
keep their checkbooks organized or they
don't know how to you know should we
really go out to dinner in this
expensive restaurant tonight when we
have the electric fuel tomorrow to pay
you know and they they'll go to the
dinner and then they have no money and I
learned that a long time ago I had to be
frugal how to manage my money every
morning when I get up
after my
coffee is is ready I sit down at my
computer I check my email and everything
my social media and then I checked my oh
no before that even I checked my what I
call my morning banking I go to my
website where I have my several accounts
make sure
no money went out that I didn't know
about and all that because I because you
you make a mistake in your checkbook and
then you get fined
ten twenty thirty dollars and I know
people that didn't care they would just
do that they would pay the fines and go
on their merry away I got real paranoid
about that when it hit me a few times
and I'm real cautious about my banking
now and um so I think it's it's a I
think it's kind of a two-way street
the creative end you put as much time
and effort as you can into learning your
craft and getting good and getting good
at it and the other thing is learn how
to manage your money and what to do with
it and how to protect yourself and lean
times and now that I have my own
production company
and I'm the only partner
I had to learn a lot of other things you
know things about
licenses you have to pay for and all
that kind of thing and taxes you pay on
certain things and and um
but you got to learn those things and
some people think it's
just nice to stay home and draw pictures
all day or write stories all day and
that's not what it's all about and
dirty and when the Dirty Harry movies
were Clint Eastwood says the man's got
to know his limitations that was really
important when that finally sunk in
because I was I wanted to I could do a
lot of things and I wanted wanted to do
them all
and none of the places none of the
things I was trying to do what we're
going anywhere and I looked at my
friends who were successful and they
were all concentrating on the thing they
did best and once I learned that
a lot of doors opened up for me I have
three rules of life
frivolous though they may sound
one is a man's got to know his
limitations Dirty Harry
second is if you think if you can't
deduct it don't spend it and you can't
always do that but a lot of times you
can't and third and this is very
important it's going to sound really
stupid but it can be applied to a lot of
things
remember the old mummy movies
The Mummy is
and he's always the guy always runs into
a cul-de-sac or something or stumbles or
something and gets killed by The Mummy
Okay the third rule if you can't outrun
The Mummy you deserve to get killed
get yourself all hooked on drugs you did
that to yourself nobody forces usually
to do that except in horror movies where
they strap you down they give you an
injection and I see so many people that
destroy their lives on drugs or alcohol
or whatever it is
um they're not out running that mummy
you know and it's hard to feel sorry for
them